so let me share with you the consensus
of what
they want i think some of these answers
came from the women that i surveyed
will surprise you they certainly did me
and i think some of these answers you're
not gonna like
i certainly didn't in fact the most
dominant and consistent answer
is the opposite of how i have been
trying to orchestrate my life
and i'll admit i'm still grappling with
how to handle this
this answer is probably best given by my
94 year old
grandmother i asked her a whole series
of questions about what she was
initially looking for in her ideal
husband
so his so his go-to source is his 94
year old grandmother
so let's start with her and then what
attracted her to my grandfather and
when did she know that she was in love
with by the way um
this man's grandfather was a world war
ii fighter pilot so his job was to fly
around
in a propeller plane shooting down the
bad guys so
let's hear what his grandmother had to
say about the grandfather and
what she wanted and more they were
married for 67
years a long time i would have been more
but my grandfather passed seven years
ago
there's not a time when i talk to my
grandmother when she doesn't say
i miss your grandfather and then recall
some loving memory
i asked her grams when did you feel most
loved by your husband
was it words of affirmation quality time
touch or intimacy
by the way the stuff he's talking about
right now is um
like the love language narrative i'm
gonna do a video dedicated to this topic
because it's
it's another piece that really sends
guys in the wrong wrong direction
i'm gonna skip over that with this
particular cast but just listen up here
to what he has to say is it the
gifts that he gave you or flowers or
compliments she interrupted me and said
flatly
when he was mopping my floors all right
let's pause for a second
when he was mopping my floors
all right i did a survey here and
um this was a few days ago we got 7 100
results let me throw it up on the screen
for you
the question was women only when is your
man most sexy attractive and desirable
to you
men if you want to see the results click
an option then unselected so if you ever
see these surveys do not take them if
it's specifically for one gender if you
want to see the results you can click
and then just unclick it and then your
vote goes away
so number one was when he has a mop in
his hand cleaning the floors in the
house
that was 11 now my female audience is
between the age of about 24
and 35 i think is what the main
categories and after that is about 35 to
45.
very uh very few are under the age or
over the age so that's going to be the
bulk of it
and about 1 in 10 of my viewers are
women just so you get the idea
that's why you don't see too many votes
in this but i think 7 100 is plenty
so having a mop in his hand and cleaning
the floors ranked at 11
uh the second highest one was or sorry
at the very bottom was when he's looking
after the kids which is six percent
so women don't want guys that are
basically taking on traditionally
feminine roles in the household
um that's not important to them uh
mopping the floors
clearly at number two is the see the
second least important thing to them
uh number three was when i see others
admire him for being on his purpose
we're getting a little warmer now you
see where we're going here
uh the fourth one is when he's doing
traditionally masculine things like
fixing or building
again another improvement in the
direction that i talk about
and the last one was when other men want
to be him and other women
desire him that was almost half of the
votes were cast
when women feel most attracted to a man
or see him as most sexy attractive
desirable when he's on his purpose
when he's putting a dent in the universe
and basically other guys want to be that
guy and other women desire him and his
attention of course
so let's move on okay so let's continue
with when graham says he was mopping the
floors
what i said my grandmother can be very
witty so i assumed she was joking
she wasn't not even a little bit she
said that is when
i knew he cared about me about our home
and about our family
and was being a man and pitching in so
skip over the fact that this guy was a
badass in the war
shooting down bad guys skip over the
fact that that he provided a house
and father children skip over the fact
that he was the protector and the
provider in the household
she's saying and this is why you can't
listen to what women say when it comes
to advice on the sexual marketplace or
what they're actually attracted to you
always have to watch their behavior
she's saying that a mop in the hand was
what she wanted the most or would turn
her on the most
still unsatisfied with this answer i
continue to question
but what does mopping force have to do
with love and intimacy and being a
heroic man
everything she said flatly here we go
and began to explain
she said running a household is a lot of
work it's unglamorous
and it's tedious work that never ends
it's work
no one likes to do it's uncelebrated and
it's taken for granted
there are no applause for a clean toilet
or fresh sheet on the bed
and all of it falls on mama's shoulders
your grandfather she continued was never
sexier
than when he had a mop in his hand and
was scrubbing my floors
did you guys see the survey that i just
took these are the words of a
post-menopausal well-past
post-menopausal
94 year old woman who's completely
forgotten about
arousal attraction desire and the main
things that are that are the drivers in
a relationship
and she's telling her grandson you
should mop the floors in the house
this is what will get you the girls this
is what will keep the girls is mopping
the floors in the house
this completely invalidates all advice
that that this guy's grandmother gave in
fact
anything that's remotely associated with
something that's tied into chore play
is something that you have to discard
the whole coining of the
of the chore play phrase basically is
you're exchanging chores
in return for intimacy could be love
could be sexual intimacy it could be any
number of things
but that's what they're that's what
they're trying to sell you guys here
with this course this is a free course
that's encouraging you to pick up mops
empty the dishwasher uh do all those
chores around the house fold laundry all
that stuff
and guess what guys that doesn't work
that is the part the process of beta
tization through a thousand concessions
you're being sold the process of beta
and this is what ends most guys in
divorce court
and what causes about eighty percent of
women because divorces we know are
initiated primarily by women it's about
8 out of 10 times
this is what is leading up to something
like this and any guy that's been
through the divorce grinder that looks
back on
when his woman was actually aroused and
attracted to him versus when she wasn't
knows full well and you i want to hear
your comments below guys
you know spill the beans knows full well
that women are not attracted to you when
you're doing short play
and you're not getting genuine
enthusiastic desire
from her it's more or less negotiated
compliance
which nobody wants because it always
leads to resentment
you